il a mordu la vie parisienne à pleines
dents pendant 30 ans avant de se retirer
dans un petit village du lot le fils
prodigue de la chanson yéyé nino ferrer
est de retour le chanteur bien sûr mais
aussi le peintre il vient de sortir un
nouveau compact disc et il expose ses
toiles jusqu'à samedi à la fnac forum
loin derrière il ya mirza gaston et son
fameux téléphone ou encore le sud
aujourd'hui nous chante le bonheur ou la
fin du monde nous l'avons rencontré au
coeur de la capitale dans les arènes de
lutèce une ville qu'il affectionne
toujours
cette solitude ce grand cercle glace et
là je me sens un peu comme rastignac
venant attaqué paris sauf que moi je
n'ai pas vraiment envie de conquérir
payet en fait j'ai quitté paris à 15 ans
maintenant je suis toujours parisien
j'ai toujours travaillé c'est ma vie je
la connais bien mais je suis toujours en
train de pester quand je suis à paris
entre la circulation le stress etc
mais bon c'est quand même ma ville et je
la revendique et être doit qu il ya trop
de voitures trop de voitures ce qui n'a
pas de voiture quoi je voudrais comme ça
se passait dans le monde ancien et comme
ça se passe toujours en campagne quand
je rencontre quelqu'un pouvoir lui
sourire ou en recevoir un sourire sans
raison comme ça à paris non plus
difficilement
on leur avec d'aider des gens jeunes
nourris avec des gens jeunes ça y est
autrement ils sont un peu renfrogné les
genres
voilà pain dans ça me remplit la vie ça
me donne la salinité bon et là j'ai
envie de refaire un disque avec de vieux
potes qui a été plus fort alors je suis
parti dans l'engrenage encore une fois
le temps
mais bon
son envie de dévorer la vie à belles
dents je m'occupais pas trop haut ni de
politique ni de ce qui se passait dans
le reste du monde qui peut et pas trop
mais après mai 68 g j'ai ouvert mon
esprit sur d'autres choses enfin j'ai
pris conscience de ce qui se passe dans
le monde
l'importance de tout ça et de la
destinée qui nous est préparé
que le monde n'est pas rose tout n'est
pas rose mais n'empêche la vie est belle
la vie est gai comme un pinson pas un
abonné des supportrices marché au
comptant est intrigué très heureux dans
la vie sturla vie complètement génial
même si l'avenir est très très sombres
e